drug use death threats and secret
identities
maslerman's elvis presley biopic takes a
few liberties with the truth and leaves
a few major things out here's everything
elvis gets wrong about elvis
as the film begins elvis has already cut
his first hit record that's alright mama
but it's his appearance on the
syndicated country music radio show
louisiana hayride that makes him a star
and brings him to the attention of
former carnival barker turned music
promoter colonel tom parker the
headliner in hayride is longtime country
star hank snow who is aghast at the way
presley gyrates in front of the crowd
later when parker convinces elvis to
strike out on his own snow seems all too
eager to see the young man gone snow's
reaction works as a symbol of how the
musical establishment of the day was
threatened by pressly and rock and roll
in general however in real life snow was
no prude both he and parker saw the
money-making potential in elvis early on
and the two even co-managed presley's
career for a short time
as the son jimmy roger snow noted years
later snow had every financial reason to
make elvis as successful as possible
even allowing elvis to close out their
shows snow's exit from the elvis presley
story in real life came at the hands of
parker who used snow to sweet talk
presley's family into signing a new
contract before cheating snow out of his
share as biographer james dickerson told
the new york post in june 2022 hank snow
said that parker was the lowest human
being that had ever walked the earth
the contract that in real life cheated
hank snow out of managing presley's
career is presented as a kind of deal
with the devil in the film presley's
manager colonel parker is seen pouring
honey into the ears of elvis parents
gladys and vernon to convince them to
sign at this point parker has already
mastermind presley's move from the
regional sun records to major label rca
victor and he solidifies his control
over the entire family by having them
sign into existence a new business
called elvis presley enterprises elvis
father vernon who had been jailed for
check forgery when his son was a boy
would be his business manager gladys is
skeptical of the colonel and would
remain so up until her death in 1958.
ultimately she signs a contract anyway
when parker coos about elvis having the
strength of two men a knowing reference
to elvis stillborn twin brother jessie
parker did indeed have elvis and his
family under contract with vernon
serving as the manager of elvis personal
business but the business venture known
as elvis presley enterprises or epe
wouldn't be formed until after presley's
death epe was founded by vernon the
presley's longtime accountant joseph
hanks and elvis ex-wife priscilla
presley as a way to preserve and manage
his estate
one of the most controversial aspects of
presley's life and legacy is his
relationship with blues music and
southern african-american culture in
general baz luhrmann's film suggests
that elvis use of black music and
culture was appreciation not
appropriation the movie works hard to
convey that the musician discovered
blues and gospels sincerely with
flashbacks showing a young elvis in a
black pentecostal church in mississippi
meanwhile the scenes of elvis's early
days in memphis show him on beale street
surrounded by the sounds of little
richard sister rosetta tharp and big
mama thornton whose hit song hound dog
would become one of elvis's signature
tombs the film also gives elvis a
friendship with blues legend bb king
already a well-known musician at the
time who views presley's fame with a
certain riot attachment however
according to biographer alana nash this
relationship seems to have been
extrapolated from a famous photograph of
the two men backstage at a memphis
charity show presley did not play at the
show but appeared briefly on stage and
gave the crowd a little leg shake in
real life king appears to have been fond
of pressly on a personal level if
ambivalent about the success elvis and
other white artists had adapting black
music
um elvis was very shy when i first met
him but there is no evidence that the
close friendship portrayed in the film
ever existed in real life
in just a few short years at the end of
the 1950s presley went from
transgressive provocateur to clean-cut
all-american family entertainer in the
film this is orchestrated by colonel
parker against elvis will starting with
a humiliating performance on the steve
allen show where he performs hound dog
with an actual dog on stage
i got you a very cute little hound dog
right here
[Music]
protesters lined the streets outside
graceland waving signs that read don't
change elvis and we want the old elvis
back at a pivotal show at the memphis
fairgrounds after being warned against
wiggling by both the memphis police and
his manager elvis's performance is so
intense that it causes a riot elvis is
taken away in a police car and is
threatened with jail or a stint in the
army while the steve allen performance
is based on a true story the memphis
fairground riots is a composite of
several different concerts most notably
during one show in jacksonville florida
a local judge warned presley against any
lewd behavior but the film gives the
impression that parker altered elvis
image under the threat of blackmail from
shadowy establishment forces which is
untrue biographer alana nash told
variety parker wanted to make elvis
clean cut after he came back from the
army in part because when elvis went
into the army neither elvis nor parker
thought rock and roll would last elvis
especially thought that it might even be
over by the time he got out
from 1956 to 1969 elvis presley starred
in over 30 hollywood movies his film
work dominated his career for the bulk
of the 60s which baslerman glides over
via a zippy montage the film seems to
believe that elvis hollywood years were
filled with hokey kids that bears little
resemblance to the transgressive
inherently political artists he was at
heart in 1968 however his conscience is
stirred by the assassinations of dr
martin luther king jr in april and
robert f kennedy in june after king's
assassination in memphis priscilla
suggests that presley should release a
statement telling him that memphis is
burning
while king's murder sparked riots and
violence in major cities across the
country the public reaction in memphis
was more muted hampton sides wrote about
king's murderer james earl ray in the
2010 book hellhound on his trail sides
explains that the first night in memphis
after the murder had isolated incidents
of violence and looting but where the
riots in other cities lasted nearly two
weeks after king's death memphis fell
into an eerie calm or a deep mourning
instead
in the movie elvis is in the midst of
filming a television comeback special
when robert kennedy's assassination
occurs in june 1968. colonel tom parker
has explicitly sold the show to nbc as a
christmas special to be aired in
december however elvis wants to use the
special to get back to his rock and roll
roots and chart a new way forward in his
career against the colonel's wishes he
ditches the christmas sweaters for a
black leather jumpsuit the resulting
concert film commonly known as the 68
comeback special is a smash hit and
latter day triumph for the
king there's been a big change in the
music fee in the last 10 or 12 years
however presley and parker's clash is
largely invented for the film in real
life the special was never meant to be a
christmas special other than by virtue
of aryan in december biographer elena
nash told variety there was never a
christmas sweater or fairy tale
christmas set that's lerman being a
showman
in the movie after the success of the
1968 comeback special pressly is writing
high and dreaming big he announces plans
to finally tour the world but first
parker books him into a weeks-long gig
at the brand new hilton international
hotel in las vegas the vegas residency
is a huge hit and gets extended presley
continues to plan his global tour but
parker has grave concerns about securing
elvis safety overseas especially when
startling death threats start showing up
in the mail the real reason parker is
delaying the start of the international
tour is because he's an illegal
immigrant and fears being deported if he
ever leaves the country the film heavily
suggests that a slew of death threats
received by pressly were staged by
parker in order to support his bogus
security concerns about traveling abroad
are you ready to fly
we may never know if some of those death
threats were forgeries by colonel tom
but thanks to the fbi we know that many
of them were very real from his earliest
days on the national scene the fbi kept
careful tabs on elvis and his activities
as director j edgar hoover feared that
he might be a corrupting influence on
the nation's youth the fbi's extensive
file on pressly contains a death threat
sent through the mail in 1956 as well as
confirmations of threats made to presley
and his associates in the 1970s
for decades colonel tom parker claimed
to be a good old boy from huntington
west virginia who ran off to join the
circus as a youth which is where he
picked up an ever so slight european
accent despite making enemies left and
right in the music business no one
seemed to mind where this carnival
barker came from as long as the money
kept rolling in the movie elvis is told
from parker's perspective and waited by
the revelations about his life that only
came to light after presley's death it
wasn't until the early 1980s that it
became widely known that parker was
actually andreas cornelius van kuk a
dutch immigrant who had briefly served
in the us army but had never become a
naturalized citizen he fled from the
netherlands in 1929 possibly after being
implicated in a murder and he still had
family in europe that he had broken all
contact with the filmmakers know all of
these things and assume that the
audience does as well which is perhaps
why tom hanks affects a thick dutch
accent throughout the movie
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children
in the film things finally come to a
head between presley and parker in 1974.
an anonymous letter reveals the truth
about parker from his illegal status to
the fact that he essentially sold elvis
to the international hotel in exchange
for unlimited credit on the casino floor
and overcome elvis collapses backstage
before show and is given a shot of
amphetamines to revive him at parker's
command once on stage the singer fires
parker in full view of the audience
however this never happened in real life
with writer alana nash telling variety
elvis would never have been so crass as
to a fired colonel from the stage
the extent to presley's addiction to
prescription drugs wouldn't come to
light until after his untimely death at
the age of 42 of a heart attack that was
likely caused by his persistent
substance abuse he had a reliance on
amphetamines or uppers to keep up with
his daunting tour schedule and
barbiturates or downers to help him
sleep especially in the last decade of
his life while it's never been confirmed
exactly how early in his career the drug
use began the movie establishes that
presley's pill habit began on the
singer's very first backwoods tour in
1955. in 1979 the new york times quoted
anonymous sources speculating that
presley's pill habit began in the 1950s
possibly due to pressley's religious
aversion to alcohol as a result the
musician allegedly felt that
prescription drugs were more legitimate
than street narcotics another rumor is
that he was snatching his mother's diet
pills long before that
according to presley biographer peter
geraldneck it was a fellow soldier who
introduced elvis to amphetamines during
his two-year stint in the army from 1958
to 1960. the truth about when elvis's
drug use really started remains unknown
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the substance abuse and mental
health services administration website
or contact samhsa's national helpline at
1-800-662-help
4350
[Applause]
[Music]